- Hi, we're, uh,
the Walsh brothers.
We used to live here.
We grew up here.
- Oh, really?
- Yes.
- We just moved in.
- Can we come in and...
- Take a look around?
- Is it okay?
- Well, I don't know.
(trumpets playing)
- Shh.
Shh.
- Oh, they changed everything.
- That's Grace.
- You know, when we lived
here it was a lot more white.
You got the blood
out of the carpet.
- Hey, what grade are you in?
- Uh, eighth.
- Oh, eighth, so you probably
do a little of this, huh?
- Hey, you got any Satriani?
- Oh, remember this is
where we used to measure our
heights when we were kids.
- Oh yeah.
And this is where we used to
measure our penis lengths.
- Right there.
- Right here.
- Our dad was a doctor.
(menacing music)
- [David] How's, uh,
everything going tonight?
- Great.
- Great?
- Yeah.
- Because you know
what time it is?
- No.
- Personal disco.
(disco music)
- And then uh...
- We had a, uh, bunk bed in here
and you know, bunk bed,
one on top of each other,
but we always slept
on the bottom.
- [Chris] Right.
- The top was for any
ladies that we would get.
We'd make them sit on the top
- We never got any ladies.
And we would poke them like
this, poke, poke, poke, poke.
- It was a fun game but
we never got any ladies,
just our sister.
You like Joe Satriani?
(gentle music)
(menacing music)
(bright music)
(police sirens)
(menacing music)
- My god, we used
to sit out here...
- Yes?
- And just look
at all the crime.
- I'll do it man.
(kid laughing)
I'll do it.
- [Young Boy] No, don't do it.
- I'll do it.
- When I lived here,
this is where all
the magic happened too.
- In the rumble room?
- No, no, this is
where my sister slept.
(woman laughing)
- Yeah, but she was
an amateur magician.
- Oh.
- Yeah, she made magic
happen everywhere.
- My sister made me drink her
pee once when I was eight.
- Oh, thank you, you know
those are really just,
these are just kind of
decorative so if you just want
to put those back there,
- [David] Is this one yours?
that would be great
- [David] Is this yours?
- You know--
- That's broken. That's broken.
- Okay, um, I was
just going to tell you
a story about Sylvia Plath.
- You got any, uh, Joe Satriani?
- No, no, we lived
here in the 90's.
We were born here in the 70's.
- No, you didn't.
This house was
built in the 80's.
- What is that right there?
(dramatic music)
(menacing music)
- Okay, I don't, can you...
- Here comes the submarine.
- [Woman] Oh my gosh.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] If you
enjoy these videos
click here to subscribe.
(sci-fi music)